As a journalist,
when I came across
something horrific,
something I wanted to
turn away from,
I couldn’t.
I hope you'll follow me.
However dark it may be.
"Truth be Told," deals
with the themes of
truth and justice
throughout the seasons.
This season,
the cases surround
missing girls
and the truth about
why they'd go missing.
Who gets national
media coverage.
Who gets media
coverage at all.
"Truth be Told."
Telling the truth is actually
one of the hardest
things for most people.
In season 3, I play a
high school principal
where a number of her students
are being trafficked.
So this season,
Poppy's podcast
is solving some
of the crimes
against these girls.
Poppy has to deal with
how much of the truth
she wants to tell.
Justice doesn't always
have truth in it.
I think we explore
that beautifully.
The more Poppy delves into
Drea's case the more she
realizes that
sex trafficking is a huge issue.
We're dealing with
topics that are
very relevant in
today's society.
You see things that
other people can't.
I'll get a few of my guys to
help me do some digging.
There's so many new dynamics.
We've really pushed
the envelope.
We delved into
a very real problem
in a very authentic way.
Gabrielle--
I feel extremely blessed
to be working opposite.
When we first meet Eva
there's a mysteriousness
around her.
I hope I didn't get
you into trouble.
Only the good kind.
Poppy has to question, is
she a friend or foe.
They each come with a
host of secrets.
There's a constant
push and pull between the two of
them that makes their
relationship very combustible.
Some untruths are worth it.
This could ruin
my entire career.
We can't let them
get away with this.
I know.
Do you?
Their approach to the same goal
is just kind of wildly
different.
That's the beauty, I
think, of season 3--
that it's not obvious.
There's mysteries within
the mysteries.
We're constantly playing in
these emotional playgrounds
and just trying to peel back
more and more layers.
I'm excited for people to see
the growth in all the
characters.
Season 3 gives us all an
opportunity to really explore
some of the personal
ups and downs
the characters are
going through.
It's a really expansive story,
but at its heart
is the dynamic of family.
There's a texture
and a grit to it.
It's really moving
to be a part of.
We get to laugh with them,
we get to cry with them,
we get to mourn with them.
The truth is messy,
it can be a little painful,
it can be dark.
But also gives us
glimmers of hope
which is all that we
can really ask for.
♪♪